Try to do this as fast as you humanly possibly
can okay don't worry about safety four seconds
four seconds to fastest time off goodness
gracious Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
they've been filming Daredevil Born Again recently
John Bernthal's Punisher is confirmed to be a huge
character during season one and now we have a
really cool clip of him in addition to teaming
up with the Thomas Jane Punisher it's Punisher
into the Punisher verse so I'll explain what's
going on and what the plan is for the Punisher
character just in general if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course I'll be doing episode videos for
Daredevil born again when it premieres next year
there'll be 18 episodes in season one so it'll
be a super size John bernthal's been preparing
for the Punisher by doing a very Punisher type
of workout a bunch of workouts like this with the
help of Thomas Jane Punisher it's so cool seeing
the two of them just hang out like dudes as far
as I know Thomas Jane isn't supposed to appear
during Daredevil born again I don't think he has
any kind of Cameo scene or anything like that he
was just there hanging out with John Bernthal
and Taryn tactical who got the video of them
together there's been a bunch of footage of John
Bernthal just working out on Daredevil born again
just in general hey we got the Punisher in the
building this this is the true it's the truth oh
he isn't messing around like he's really bringing
it and it would be cool to see a cameo scene from
Thomas Jane is either another vigilante even
if he's not playing his version of The Punisher
in New York City who Daredevil has to deal with
we'll cross our fingers for a secret Wars Cameo
scene because everybody's ever thought of being
in a Marvel movie or TV show for the last like 60
70 years is probably going to be in that movie
the whole idea with Punisher during Daredevil
born again is the Kingpin is running for mayor
of New York City just like he was in the comics
and is part of what he does to get the public
to like him because he is the Kingpin of crime
he's a villain part of the way he turns public
opinion in his favor is based on the comic book
Arc that they're adapting where he essentially
takes a hard-line stance against vigilantes
in New York City like his whole platform is
anti-vigilante so he uses the police all these
above-board government assets that he has at his
disposal now as mayor to get rid of all the good
Vigilantes like Daredevil for instance and that
makes it easier for him to do all the Shady mob
related stuff that he wants to controlling all
of New York City but doing so with an iron fist
to make another defender's reference not expecting
any kind of Iron Fist Cameo scene though normally
we say Kingpin controls New York City but he does
so from the Shadows because he controls all the
major crime families but when he becomes mayor of
New York City he can do all that stuff during the
day and he can make people love him for it during
that same Arc he also winds up hiring Daredevil
as a city prosecutor so Daredevil is forced to
help Kingpin prosecute and get rid of all these
Vigilantes like Punisher who as hardcore as he
is as much collateral damage as Punisher causes
he's still meant to be a good character trying to
get rid of the worst criminals Vincent D'Onofrio
even talked about season two confirming that
there would be a season two I'll explain that
Andy even talked about Spider-Man so I'll explain
how this connects with the plot of Spider-Man 4.
feeling that and I've said
this since I started the
net eventually I'm gonna kick Spider-Man's ass
cannot wait to see Daredevil and Spider-Man
team up to fight Kingpin and for Kingpin to
try and squish him some Spider-Man they're gonna
be filming the series all this year all the way to
December so we're gonna get a bunch more scenes
much more of them talking about new characters
and connecting with the upcoming Marvel movies of
course I will do videos for everything and I will
do videos for all the episodes when they start
releasing them there will be 18 episodes total
in season one but they are going to break the
season I believe into two halves like there'll
be two Coors if you watch anime they do that all
the time like season one part one and season one
part two but Vincent D'Onofrio recently explained
they are developing season two so there will be
multiple seasons of the show in addition to these
18 episodes that they're currently filming the
new scenes that they're filming also help set up
what's going to be happening during the events of
Spider-Man 4 so I'll explain how that all fits
together probably one of the biggest new scenes
is you see Vince Kingpin as he's going to appear
during the series at least at the beginning of
the series it is a scene of him throwing a rally
for his mayoral campaign confirming that he is
going to be running for mayor during the series
mayor Kingpin like he did in the comics they're
also in the middle of celebrating New Year's Eve
in Times Square here for New Year's Eve 2026 so
it's 2025 December heading into the year 2026.
we had just hit winter at the end of Spider-Man
no way home so this is set like right after
that and also after the events of the Hawkeye
series because that was set around the same time
heading into that December holiday period look the
Christmas tree was already up in Rockefeller
Center in both Spider-Man no way home and the
Hawkeye series there are a couple Easter eggs
you notice in the background like one of them
is actually dressed as Spider-Man so that just
confirms that the crowd knows of Spider-Man the
whole spell that they did in Spider-Man Away
Home are the two different spells just erase
the knowledge that Peter Parker was Spider-Man
so they know that Spider-Man exists they just
don't know that he's Peter Parker you also see
the people celebrating New Year's Eve waving
the banners that say pimtech and Van Dyne Tech
that's from Ant-Man the WASP quanta Mania so
this is one of the other connections to the
Marvel movies that are happening right now
they explained during Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania that hope Van Dyne had taken
over her father's company after Avengers end game
and just updated the name and she was using Pim
particles to try and cure a lot of the world's
basic problems so she's using the company and
pin particles for a lot of philanthropy there's
a big QR code in the background they might wind
up turning that into free comics that you can scan
when the episodes actually happen they do that in
all the Marvel Disney plus series like during Moon
night during She-Hulk all the other ones even the
Hawkeye series you scan those you get free comics
and usually the comics they give away are based on
the plot of whatever those episodes are I'm also
assuming because of the comic book panel zoom and
enhance in the background here that the Free Comic
they give away is related to this particular comic
and it's actually from Daredevil number 595 which
is from mayor Fisk number one the beginning of the
mayor fist mayor Kingpin storyline confirming
that he is going to be doing that during this
because you see one of the banners on the ground
that says Fisk it's one of his supporters that
plans on voting for him during the mayoral race
in the comic book panel you see Kingpin wearing
an outfit like we saw him wearing during Hawkeye
without the Hawaiian shirt like it's a similar hat
and during it he's thinking to himself the choice
between good and evil Rises and Falls within you
like swells rolling in on the tide which side do
you choose the crest or the trough so it's him
getting ready to address this crowd his supporters
the people that he's trying to get to vote for him
and it's meant to show you how he thinks why
does he choose to either do terrible things or
good things and they make it seem like he could
go either way at any given moment like it just
like swells rolling in on the tide I could be evil
one moment I could be good the next and the whole
idea here with Kingpin running for mayor is that
it's meant to be part of this dark rain era in
Marvel phase five that they're heading into after
the events of secret Invasion which is similar to
the progression in the comic book storylines like
you went from the secret invasion of the comics
into dark Reign where the villains basically take
over so it's like a rise of the villains phase in
Marvel and the way they're playing this along with
some of the other scenes like you see a bunch of
Kingpin flashbacks that I'll explain to the 19
70s when he was a little bit older like after
the events of the flashbacks and the Netflix
scenes when he was much younger when you saw
him kill his father in present day it's meant to
be a dark Twist on the Iron Man Avengers Age of
Ultron moment where he said that he got paranoid
after the events of the first Avengers moving the
shitari invasion in wanted to protect the Earth by
wrapping it in a suit of armor in the whole idea
during Avengers Age of Ultron as they found out
that was a terrible idea it led to very terrible
things like it led to Ultron in now after secret
Invasion we're getting ready for those episodes
we're going to see the squirrels try to take
over again eventually they'll be found out and
it sounds like they're giving a lot of the Norman
Osborne storyline to Thunderbolt Ross who's been
recast as Harrison Ford they're going to defeat
the Scrolls in Thunderbolt Ross and Val will take
credit for that and ride that wave of popularity
in the populace to get into the White House and
it'll be a very Thanos type of moment like where
Thanos said fine I'll do it myself but it'll be
Thunderbolt Ross doing that turning the United
States into something more akin to a police day
protecting it like because that's this whole
thing he wants to protect the United States
at the expense of everyone else but his idea
of a protected safe United States is way more
hardcore like a more Punisher type of version of
the United States the only people threatening the
planet would be people which is also one of the
reasons why they're bringing Punisher back during
Daredevil born again so the whole idea is that
Kingpin is running for mayor because he wants
to control New York City control the mob that's
why he wants to become Kingpin in the first place
but he's doing it because inside like deep down
he thinks he's trying to protect New York City
turning it into a place that he would want to
live in when he was a child because all these
Kingpin flashbacks that you see to the 1970s you
see all these kids I think they're trying to show
you more context for how dangerous New York City
was in the 1970s like people tell stories about
how bad things were in the 70s in New York City
in real life he'll Rule New York City with an
iron fist in the whole idea is that Daredevil is
going to try and continue being Daredevil like
how do you beat Daredevil be the good guy because
the other big thing that happens right after this
moment in the Comics is that Daredevil goes to
work for mayor Kingpin like how do you get rid
of the dude you hate who you know is doing evil
stuff when everybody loves him and you're forced
to work for him for those of you asking about
Karen Page and foggy Nelson coming back from
the Netflix series I think they will come back
eventually they're just not in the first couple
of episodes so they haven't been brought back yet
the key word is yet this is Charlie Cox talking
about them coming back I think this if you're
a true dead of a fan a mega bro I don't know
but I think that I feel like there's probably
no escaping that there is only one Karen Page
so he's basically saying during that the Karen
Page is Daredevil's best girl she will eventually
probably come back just not right away if you
have any other questions about what's going
on in Daredevil born again or the other Netflix
characters just write them Below in the comments
I'm still working on a bunch of other videos be
sure to enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss those if you have any special requests leave
them in the comments below too there's a bunch of
stuff happening this week everyone click here
for my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 Alpha group
video and click here for my Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 post credit scene video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!